puis la création de la région grand est
l'alsace n'a plus d'existence
administrative
c'est un manque évidemment pour les
habitants et leurs représentants et
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement est prêt
à soutenir la création d'une
collectivité alsacienne
elle rassemblerait le haut-rhin et le
bas-rhin felip vogel et laurence clause
de pierre le dialecte une identité rozon
10 pieds et désire depuis la réforme
territoriale de 2015 officiellement
l'alsace n'existe plus intégré au sein
d'une grande région est une nouvelle
carte jamais vraiment comprise par les
alsaciens avec pour une majorité d'entre
eux l'impression d'avoir été noyés dans
la masse c'est dommage de scinder les
régions comme ça ou d'en faire une
énorme région qui n'a rien à voir avec
presque jusqu'à paris je pense que des
alsaciens auraient accepté facilement
une région alsace
asaf lorraine mais rajouter champagne
ardenne ça a été un coup de massue à
mauvais souvenir peut-être enfin oublié
d'ici peu l'alsace devrait renaître sous
la forme d'une nouvelle collectivité
unique regroupant le bas rhin et le haut
rhin avec des compétences propres
économique culturelle ou linguistique
les alsaciens soutiennent et
applaudissent alors qu elle est toujours
restée une entité alsace depuis
longtemps que la plupart des alsaciens
l'ont demandé comme ça la corse l'alsace
on a beaucoup de choses qui nous
diversifie par rapport à d'autres
régions se soit déjà rien qu'avec le
système sécurité sociale le premier
ministre devrait définitivement tranchée
d'ici la semaine prochaine et donner un
nom à cette nouvelle collectivité et
l'alsace pourraient ainsi à nouveau
existait toujours au sein de la région
grand est mais avec un statut
particulier